[Music]
today i want to come and see how much
further we can bring that and implement
it in schools
it's actually a great opportunity i can
see how he thinks and
how he executes things
[Applause]
it's also a bit comforting knowing that
there are people older than us who are
also learning about the same thing
i think my dad is nervous to work with
my teacher
our challenge statement allows us to
look into the real world problem that we
are currently facing addressing mental
well-being to getting independence and
to think of solutions to solve that
problem in a real-world context
[Applause]
when we talk about the needs of the
students we see one side of the story
where the parents sometimes see the
other side the program was a great
chance for us to actually work together
in a team
[Music]
when you hear from different
perspectives especially from the
children themselves you get a chance to
really hear what they think and not only
from a cognitive level but also from an
emotional level
it inspires me to listen
more to the kids offer them a platform
to speak up and share their ideas
they're very encouraging they let me
finish what i have to say
i think there's no right or wrong answer
there's nothing wrong in having your own
opinion
the youth are going to be the agent of
change moving forward where to allow the
student the space to explore to give
them room to make error that's how we
build them up
i feel like a proud parent i see the
effort that he has put in and i see the
growth in him throughout the three weeks
it was really nice to see how the ideas
that we came up with along the way
really just came together
[Applause]
[Music]
i was very happy to receive the
certificate and it was something that i
felt proud of
i think this experience will give me a
chance to think whether i should adjust
my role let my daughter have more
control what she wants to do
this workshop actually brings on a lot
of good bonding with the parents and the
children gives them an area to open up
any fears that they might have but they
might not show it up in front of the
parent
[Music]
[Applause]
and run our schools in a more empathetic
way so that we bring solutions to the
real world that are making sense to
everyone around us
[Music]
you